Let's look at the solution to
our DRAM access scheduling quiz.
So we have 32 arrays,
each is 16 megabits and
takes a 12 bit row address,
and a 12 bit column address.
Twelve bits is three hex digits, so
the row address will be the upper
three hex digits, and the column
address will be the lower hex digits.
Each of these corresponds to
a 32-bit memory location.
So what happens is each of these
arrays sees the same address, but
it provides a different bit for
that address.
So each address will have the same
sequence of row and column addresses,
it's just that they will implement
different bits of that address.
So what we have here is the first one,
of course, needs to be a page open.
So we have 10 nanoseconds
to open this first page.
We will then read in two nanoseconds,
then we will close the page
in another five nanoseconds, because
the next one is on a different page.
The row address is different.
So we spent 17 nanoseconds here,
we will spend another 17 here,
we will then spend another 17 here
because it's again in a different row.
17 here and here and here and here.
Overall, we have 7 accesses,
each to a different page, so
each of them requires 17 nanoseconds,
for
a total of 119 nanoseconds.
Now let's try to reorganize these.
What we want to do when we reorganize
these, is once we open a page, access
everything on that page before we move
on, which means we will open this row,
and then we will access everything in
that row, which means this and this too.
Now, what happens is we spend
10 nanoseconds opening that row,
3 times 2 nanoseconds reading
these three things, and
then we need to close the row
in another 5 nanoseconds.
Then what happens is we
open the next row, and
we read everything from that row,
which includes this too, so
we end up opening one row, reading two
things from it, and then closing it.
And now we spend 17 nanoseconds for
each one of these.
In total, we spent 74 nanoseconds
doing these accesses.
So as you can see, when caches have
a number of pending misses and we need
to send these misses to memory, it pays
to rearrange the order of the addresses
we are accessing to benefit from
the organization of the data.